-Our next guest is
a very funny comedian and writer
whose work you've seen on
"Desus and Mero,"
"Our Cartoon President,"
and "Yearly Departed."
Her new show, "Ziwe,"
premieres on Showtime
this Sunday, May 9th.
Let's take a look.
-I'm honored
that you're doing the show
But my question is
why did you agree to this?
Do you know who I am?
-I don't have the slightest idea
who you are.
♪♪♪♪
Someone who worked for you
was incredibly persistent,
incredibly persistent
to the point
where this just seemed easier.
-So, shout-out to the
persistence of women of color.
Really.
-Yes, or any persistence.
-Please welcome to the sho
and the studio Ziwe!
♪♪♪♪
Hello.
-Hi.
-Welcome.
-Hi. Thanks for having me.
-Everyone's so happy
you're here.
-Hi, guys.
-Join us. Join us, Ziwe.
♪♪♪♪
Hi. How are you?
-Good. How are you?
-I am very well.
I sort of became aware of
your work this year,
particularly on Instagram Live
I was unaware
that we had met before.
-Yes, we did.
-This was in 2013.
We went -- We both went
to Northwestern University
-Yes.
-And I went back for
some sort of alumni event,
and there we are.
-Yeah. You were trying to
avoid eye contact with me.
And I confronted you
into taking the photo.
-Much like with Fran.
-Yes.
I've been doing the same bit
for years.
-And I was very touched becaus
you wrote "My writing hero
in the tag and then I came
right back down to Earth
because you misspelled my name
You didn't --
-Okay, so, in my defense,
autocorrect wasn't as poppin
on a BlackBerry Pearl.
-Oh, yeah. That's true.
-So I'm sorry.
-We're going to blame it
on the BlackBerry?
I love your style.
You know, you've sort of
made a name for yourself
having very honest conversations
about race
in a really funny way.
Is that what we can expect
from the show as well?
-Yes. It's going to be
a lot of really tense, silly
bombastic conversations
with lots of music videos
and sketches and field pieces.
But it really is a wild time
And you'll see interviews
you've never seen before.
-So you took advantage of
Instagram Live
during a time when a lot o
comedians, obviously,
were suffering from not having
a room full of people
to do their act to,
and "Baited" was this way
to talk to people.
And what made you use
this platform?
And why do you think
people enjoyed it so much?
-Instagram Live? So I --
At the height of the pandemic,
I had nothing to do.
You couldn't go outside.
I was afraid that if I wen
outside, I'd get COVID.
And everyone was going liv
on Instagram every 15 minutes,
and so I thought I would joi
that cacophony of notification
with my own type of show.
But I was too lazy to do, like
a musical production.
So I decided to do interviews,
which are kind of more --
it's just -- I like
to talk to people.
So what started off as, like
you know, this program
with 30 viewers and, like,
very, very --
comedians who are just
my friends turned into
I guess -- I don't know --
a phenomenon?
What do you -- what do you
say about yourself?
-It certainly went from that
to a show on television.
So I'm going to allow
phenomenon.
-Yeah, yeah. I mean, yes.
Yeah, it's wild.
One day, I book
Caroline Calloway.
Then the next week,
I do Alison Roman.
And then the next week,
I do Rose McGowan.
And then, suddenly,
the show blew up.
-And was it --
were you surprised that
you were starting to get guest
with sort of bigger
and bigger name recognition?
Or did it happen so quickl
that you didn't
even have time
to step back and say,
"Oh, I can't believe
this is happening"?
-Both because I come from
a live performing background
in New York.
I've been performing live to
very small audiences forever
And so I've become accustome
to DMing people,
begging them to do my show
so yes.
But the production behind it
was part of my skill set.
-One of the things about
Instagram Live, of course,
is you sort of can't block
anyone from coming to watch.
-Yeah, that's true.
-And I would assume you have
family members who realize
there was this opportunity
to watch you.
And what was their feedbac
on the show?
-Well, so, my Nigerian aun
famously said that
I was very sweet but I needed to
be kinder to Democrats.
-Oh.
-And I took those notes
with a grain of salt,
but also -- look, I --
it allows me to reflect
on myself
because, hey, I should be nice
to Democrats.
-[ Laughs ]
That's very -- It's good.
-It's good advice.
-I heard you tell
that somebody that you model
your interviewing style afte
and that you're very inspired by
is Andy Cohen's work
with the Housewives.
-Yes. I'm a "Housewife" fanatic.
I watch "Beverly Hills,"
"Auckland,"
"Dallas," everything,
"Orange County."
And I would watch these
interviews that -- the reunions,
rather, that Andy would do wit
the characters, I call them.
And he'd say,
"Hey, character, you know,
Monique from New Jersey says
your boobs look awful."
And they would have --
"What do you --
What do you have
to say about that?"
And they'd have to answer.
And they'd be put on the spo
and really tense
but they'd still reveal that
about themselves.
And so -- Or, like,
he'd confront, like,
Camille Grammer
about her marriage.
And so I thought, "Why can I
not have -- I...
How can I ask questions
that confront people
but about race and politic
and social-political
structures?"
So it's like doing Andy but with
a little political bend.
-When you were a BlackBerr
Pearl-toting college student
did you know this is
what you wanted to be doing?
Comedy writing?
-When I took that photo
with you, yes, but I started
college as a math major.
But then I was, like, a poetry
lover and I loved words.
And I was like,
"All poets are very poor.
How am I going to support my
parents who sacrificed so much
to come to this country?"
And so I did this internship
at Comedy Central.
It was a rotational progra
that was the Chris Rock interns.
And I fell in love with comedy
I got a joke on "Colbert Report"
as an intern
that was really chatty.
And I was like, "Okay, this is
easy. It's great."
And so I went back to Chicago,
did The Onion and then iO,
and a bunch of other stuff
-Now, when your parents sent you
off to Northwestern
as a math major,
how did they take the news
when you went back to them
and said, "Change of plans"?
-I don't think my parents know
what I do for a living today
-Even to this day?
-Yes. They're still in denial.
So, ultimately, it's fine.
-Do they think -- When they hear
you're on the show tonight
will they assume it's going to
be a math-based interview?
-Yes, they'll see
lots of equations.
And they'll be like, "Wow, Ziwe,
you didn't talk about calculus
at all."
And I don't remember
a damn thing, so...
-Well, congratulations
on the show.
-Thank you.
-It is so lovely
to see you again.
I remember taking that photo -
-Do you really? No, you don't.
-No, I don't.
-No, you don't.
[ Laughter ]
-But in the retelling of it,
because I do like to do
revisionist history,
I'll say,
"You know, I went back.
I went to this football game
And there was this one perso
who I thought,
'Sky's the limit.'"
-And she was screaming,
"Go, Cats!"
-Go, Cats!
Thank you so much
for being here.
That's Ziwe, everybody.
Her show, "Ziwe," premiere
this Sunday, May 9th,
at 11 p.m. on Showtime.